[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Welcome to the stage.
We have got the director
Scott Elliott, hi.
And actors, yes--
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Actors, yay!
Actors Annapurna Sriram,
said that correctly, yes.
And Matthew Broderick,
and of course,
actor/playwright Wallace Shawn.
So I actually want to start out
reading a quote from Zachary
Stewart from Theater Mania.
"'Evening at the Talk House'
isn't really a disturbing look
at our possible near future
but our very real present."
I'm going to let that
sit for a second.
Have you heard that?
WALLACE SHAWN: I am
not allowed to say.
SPEAKER 1: Well, I guess for
the benefit of the audience,
can you give a little
bit, a brief synopsis
of the story of what
the show actually is?
As the playwright?
WALLACE SHAWN: OK, why me?
But I'll try.
Well, like everything
I've written,
it's actually more
interesting than it sounds.
It's very boring to describe.
But there's a
group of people put
on a play in a made-up country,
I suppose, 10 years earlier.
And somebody has the idea
to have a reunion of people
who worked on the play.
And so they decide they're
going to meet in a club
where they used to
go after the show.
And there's one guy
who wasn't invited,
but who's there anyway.
SPEAKER 1: Your character.
WALLACE SHAWN: And there are
two people who work in the club.
And there are five people
who are getting together.
And during the 10 years, a lot
has happened in that country.
Some people, some
of the five people
have gone way up in the world.
And well, theater has
kind of faded out.
There isn't any theater anymore.
But the writer
and the main actor
have gone way up in the world,
working on a television show.
And then three of the
people have gone way down
in the world.
And the world has changed.
And that's the setting
of the play, I would say.
SPEAKER 1: So what exactly
is the Talk House then?
WALLACE SHAWN:
Well, the Talk House
is a club that has seen
much better days it's
in a sort of theatrical
neighborhood.
As theater has declined,
so has the club.
It's a shell of its former self.
But they keep it going.
SPEAKER 1: So the Talk
House, the whole theater,
Matthew Broderick's
character is the playwright.
It starts out the whole
thing with this monologue
that seemed to go forever.
I didn't know if
the whole show was
going to be a
monologue, which I was
like, that was just amazing.
Props to you for
remembering all of that.
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW BRODERICK: More or less.
SPEAKER 1: Do you ever screw
up the lines every night?
And does Wallace come and
beat you with a hammer?
MATTHEW BRODERICK: No, he
doesn't beat me with a hammer.
But I pretty much don't
screw up the monologue.
I'll miss a few words
or a few sentences.
The first couple of
times I definitely had
to stop a few times.
But Wally is sitting, as
it's staged, right next to me
or very near me.
You know the writer
is right there,
so you're trying
to say it properly.
And I always have in my head
that if I got very mixed up
I would just turn to Wally.
He knows this and that he
will tell me what's next.
SPEAKER 1: Has
that ever happened?
MATTHEW BRODERICK:
Not so far, but I'll
make it happen by
talking about it.
SPEAKER 1: It's in here,
so the energy stays here.
MATTHEW BRODERICK: It's 11 pages
without anybody else talking.
So it takes a while to learn.
SPEAKER 1: Right,
and that's what?
That's about--
MATTHEW BRODERICK: See
I wish I had this thing.
Then it would be
a piece of cake.
SPEAKER 1: This is
saying it as we say it.
So it's one of those--
MATTHEW BRODERICK: It would
have to work in a slightly
different way in order to--
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, this is
feeding me all my lines.
MATTHEW BRODERICK: I can't tell
what's coming first, me or it.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Getting back to
the actual show, I guess.
I mean, we could talk about
open captioning all day long.
It's very cool.
I mean, I don't want to
give away too many spoilers,
I guess.
I don't want to give
away any spoilers, but--
WALLACE SHAWN: Well, I
mean, does it matter?
Because in a way the play is--
SPEAKER 1: By the time it's
written, it's already happened.
WALLACE SHAWN: The play--
don't know-- I mean, the play
is sold out for the last week.
So it's only playing one
more week and it's sold out.
So in a way it doesn't matter.
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW BRODERICK: We'll
do it for you right now.
[LAUGHTER]
WALLACE SHAWN: Yeah,
I mean, so I'll
be a little more
forthcoming, should I?
SPEAKER 1: Yes, go ahead.
WALLACE SHAWN: It
doesn't matter.
SPEAKER 2: Or extend the run.
SPEAKER 1: Or extend
the run, yeah.
WALLACE SHAWN: Well,
that would be great.
We can't do that.
And when--
[LAUGHTER]
I mean one of the sad things
about New York theater is--
I'm not saying the play--
it's sold out possibly
for reasons that have nothing
to do with anybody liking it.
But it is a sad fact
that a play like this--
there possibly
was a time when it
could have moved to a
somewhat bigger theater
and played for
another few months,
and more people
could have seen it.
And now the economics
of the New York theater
make that completely impossible.
You either have to
do this limited run--
we've done six weeks--
or be on Broadway,
where you have
to convince 1,000 people to
come every night for a year
or something in order to
make it pay for itself,
including people who
wouldn't like this play.
Sad story, but anyway.
I mean not to be self-pitying.
It's just sad.
Well, it is self-pity, I guess.
[LAUGHTER]
The play turns out to be--
the world that you see in
the play is quite grim.
And people who read the
newspaper occasionally
say it reminds them of the
times that we're living in
or what Trump would
like the world to be
or something like that.
It has a-- people come out
saying well, that was creepy.
SPEAKER 1: So that actually
got touched on a little bit,
I guess.
I couldn't quite figure out
until I was reading up on it
a little bit more afterwards
if it was like a slightly
different parallel universe.
Like if you believe
in the multiverse,
if we're just like
one iota over.
And this just got a little
more creepy in one direction.
Or if it was sort of
a dystopian future,
maybe even no less
than 20 years from now.
Scott, as the director, it's
not exactly clear in the writing
from my perspective--
I don't know if you were
trying to make it that way,
apologies if you did--
but like from your
perspective as a director,
did you take the
action, did you take
the flow of the show
in any particular,
I guess one or the other of
either present but different
or future?
SCOTT ELLIOT: Well,
I don't really see it
as futuristic in that way.
I never saw it that way.
I saw it as a--
I sort of pretended
like it was today.
And when little
bits of information
came out that sort
of lets people
know that it isn't today,
I think it creates--
it makes everybody
that's watching
it feel that quite possibly
it could be tomorrow.
And that's sort of the
take that I had on it.
And as far as hinting
to the future,
I made a decision to not hint
to the future in any way,
except for those--
well, there's a set.
And there's theater posters
around the top of the set.
And for those people who
might know about that world,
there's several posters that--
plays that have never
actually happened.
So that was the sort
of wink to the future
for people who might know that.
But I sort of see the play as,
you know, that it feels close.
It felt close to me,
considering the political--
especially considering that
when we started working on it
was right in the
middle of the election
and, I mean, I think
we were rehearsing
during the inauguration.
But we decided to do the
play quite a long time ago.
And Wally wrote the
play several years ago,
and the fact that
it felt so urgent
made it exciting and also
a little creepy and scary.
SPEAKER 1: Was it written
for you and The New Group?
SCOTT ELLIOT: Yes, he wrote
it specifically for me.
No, the play was done at the
National Theater in London
first.
It was always the plan to do
it at The New Group in New York
after.
But he didn't-- I don't
think-- you didn't write it
for a specific theater,
he just wrote it.
And then that was
just what happened.
But we didn't do it in
London, a whole other group
did it in London.
And we did it in New York.
And fortunately, I think the
timing of the whole thing
worked out even better
for us just because
of the political environment.
SPEAKER 1: Did you have to
change anything, moving it?
How was the theater
different from the one here?
The one here,
you're looking down.
The audience is on both sides.
SCOTT ELLIOT: Yeah, it's a
completely different staging
in London.
They did it on a regular
stage, like what you would
say is a proscenium stage.
But here we sort of
made the decision
to, or I guess I
made the decision to,
sort of use the audience
as part of the experience.
I know, you saw it, so you know
that at the very beginning,
people come in.
And all the actors are
already on the stage.
And people are having
little snacks and drinks
with each other to
sort of warm everybody
up and think everybody was
in for some happy experience.
And then they sit down, and
it sort of starts happy.
But then, yeah, the
idea was sort of
to make everybody
feel a part of it.
SPEAKER 1: We're dangling the
carrot of all this creepiness.
And they have no idea
what we're talking about.
SCOTT ELLIOT: Exactly.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: We
can talk about it.
SCOTT ELLIOT: You never will.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM:
I mean we can--
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: We'll get there.
We have 40 minutes to kill.
So we'll get there.
We talked about the beginning.
I came in and it was like
gummy worms and marshmallows
and colored water.
What was the decision
behind the candy
to serve people as like
hors d'oeuvres to the show?
SCOTT ELLIOT: Well,
I wanted everybody
to have a little something.
And I thought it
would be nice to have
something sweet, a little sweet
something before the show.
And most people aren't
allergic to marshmallows
and gummy worms.
But no peanuts allowed.
SPEAKER 1: So peanuts
and shellfish.
SCOTT ELLIOT: Yeah,
but I thought just
to give everybody
a little something.
And of course there
is-- well, spoilers
don't matter, as you say.
But somebody is
poisoned in the play
by drinking something that
somebody on the stage, you
know, poisoned somebody.
And I thought it'd be fun
to have the audience have
a little drink before,
too, and go home and be
worried that they might die.
[LAUGHTER]
So that was sort of--
that was the idea behind it.
SPEAKER 1: Well, so how
did everybody then--
and obviously we know
how you got connected.
And Scott, it sounds like
you and Wally are friends.
SCOTT ELLIOT: We've
done many shows together
and we're, I think,
very good friends.
SPEAKER 1: So Matthew and--
so AP you want to be,
yes, to be called.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: It will
be easier than Annapurna.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
AP and Matthew, how
did the two of you
get connected to the show?
MATTHEW BRODERICK: Duh--
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: Do
you want to go first?
MATTHEW BRODERICK: Well,
do you want to go first?
You can go first.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: I
did a show with Scott
that he directed
almost two years ago.
And then it moved to London.
So then I worked
on the same show.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SCOTT ELLIOT: You know
that Jesse and Kunal did--
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: Yeah,
I did "The Spoils."
SCOTT ELLIOT: They did
a talk here as well.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: You
might have seen it.
SCOTT ELLIOT: You weren't
invited to that one.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: I wasn't
SCOTT ELLIOT: You've
moved up in the world.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: And Scott
called and e-mailed me
the script and asked
me to do the role
that I do in this play,
which is a complete 180
from "The Spoils."
And I said yes, because I
love Wally and I love Scott.
And I--
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW BRODERICK: Thank you.
And now me?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, your turn.
MATTHEW BRODERICK:
I'm waiting to see
what I'm supposed to say.
SCOTT ELLIOT: What if it
says somebody else's name
while you talk?
That's very disconcerting.
I said something.
And it said Matthew Broderick.
I don't want you to
have credit for--
MATTHEW BRODERICK: I guess you
guys all see this a lot so it's
boring to talk about that.
What happened to me is I
ran into Wally at Eataly.
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW BRODERICK: It's true.
I mean we knew each other from--
we did-- I did a film
version of a play
that Wally wrote called "Marie
and Bruce" a few years ago.
So we knew each other.
And then we were shopping,
and he said he had a play.
It's really what happened.
And this was the London version.
But I wasn't able to go
to London at that point.
And I think,
believe, it was also
to play the part that
you're now playing.
And I stressed and stressed,
but I couldn't figure out
how to go to England.
And then fortunately, however
much later, it got done here.
And then it was
a different part.
And it was Scott, who I
knew also from before.
And I just--
I love both of
them, and you, too.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: There's so much
love on the stage now.
MATTHEW BRODERICK: I love you.
SPEAKER 1: I love all of you.
That's why you're all here.
MATTHEW BRODERICK:
I love Google.
Google Docs, I like.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: Gmail.
MATTHEW BRODERICK: Gmail.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM:
Yeah, I love Gmail.
SPEAKER 1: We have a
little search engine, too.
Maybe you've used it.
MATTHEW BRODERICK: I
don't like that part.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: So Wally, did
you intend on playing Dick,
or did you just want to
write it and walk away?
WALLACE SHAWN: No, I planned
to write it and walk away.
And I mean this is a
question for Scott, really.
But you know, well, Matthew and
three other very good people
turned down my part in London.
And we were-- so there
was a kind of a--
we couldn't cast
the part in London.
So the director
asked me to do it.
And I really didn't
want to be in the play.
Because there's a kind of
dignity involved in not being--
I mean in being able to say,
oh, yes, I wrote that play.
Those other people are doing it.
There is a kind of--
I feel that if I am involved,
it's as if somehow--
I don't know quite
know how to put it.
It's a feeling that nobody but
my mother would come to see it
or that I have to be in it in
order to sort of push it along.
Because nobody-- a group
of people who are not me
would not really want to do it.
So I find it embarrassing
to be in my own play.
And I had hoped on this
occasion to not be in it.
But I think Scott felt he
must be in it because I'm
going to change him.
I'm going to make him into
a better actor of the kind
that I approve of.
[LAUGHTER]
And this strangely
did happen in a way.
The response, a lot of people
have said to me, in effect,
you're--
that was a very
good performance.
[LAUGHTER]
I think you actually were
all right as an actor.
And so I think that's why
I'm in it on this occasion.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: Yeah, me, too.
Scott could make
me a better actor.
WALLACE SHAWN: I mean it is--
because again, I said I
don't want to be in it.
But in this case, we didn't
audition anybody else.
I mean he said no,
you have to be in it.
SPEAKER 1: Did you audition
the rest of the roles, too?
WALLACE SHAWN: No,
the interesting thing
about this play is
we had no auditions.
And the people,
except for Annapurna,
that's what I call AP,
except for Annapurna, all
of the people in the play are
people who really have logged
many decades or in
that strange phrase,
they devoted their
life to the theater.
Because the play is about
people involved with theater,
and I think Scott
wanted it to have
a certain authenticity and a
certain knowledge behind it.
I mean, in a way,
the play could be
about a group of people
working at Google
who meet 10 years later.
It's not really, in some way I
mean the political story is not
really related necessarily
to their being actors.
But the play has a certain--
it's a better play,
probably, because I
know something about theater,
whereas I don't know anything
about working at Google.
So it was great then to
get a group of people
together who all have been in
those particular circumstances.
SPEAKER 1: So I guess,
AP, being the one
without the decades
of experience,
did you approach your character
any differently than you feel--
than the other actors
did, or are you
just sitting back
and feeling the love
and absorbing from
their wiseness?
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM:
Well, I don't really
know how everyone else
approached their character
to know if I did
it any differently.
I have sort of a strange--
a stranger part.
Because I don't really talk--
I'm the waitress
at the Talk House.
SPEAKER 1: I think you
actually served me my water.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: Yeah, and I'm
one of the slave-- servants--
[LAUGHTER]
In the beginning, when people
walk in and I'm serving them
and most people I don't think
even think I'm in the show.
So I think they think I'm
just an usher or something.
And they usually ask me
where their seats are.
And like then they'll move
on to Wally or Matthew
and talk to them about them.
So and then my character for
the first hour of the show
is I'm just making drinks
for the people at the party.
And I'm bringing out food
and then clearing food
off the table.
I'm really just
being a waitress.
And then it isn't until about
an hour in that I'm actually
sort of invited to join the
discussion or join the party.
And can I?
Should I reveal more?
OK, so then it's
sort of revealed
that my character had
been working as-- so can I
tell some of those plot points?
OK, so there's this
sort of discussion
about this kind of
like droning, but they
call it targeting in the
world that the play's set in.
And there is a heated, sort
of political discussion
about how people
feel about targeting
and who does targeting.
And it's people do targeting
as like a part-time job
if they need some extra money.
And then-- so when
I finally come in,
I'm like a failed actor.
And it's revealed that I had
been working as a murderer
after I was sort of a failed
actor in this 10-year gap.
Because I had been a
waitress at the place.
And then in that 10-year
gap, I was a failed actor,
and then I worked as
a murderer and now I'm
back being a waitress.
SPEAKER 1: It's the
natural progression.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM:
Yeah, yeah, there's
definitely a lot of like oh,
this is too close to home.
[LAUGHTER]
So I think that--
so I have sort of a different
perspective than everyone else
because all the other people
are older and had more success
or are sort of able
to ignore or not
be as affected by the
change of society, which
involves a lot more murdering
and droning and targeted
assassination.
SPEAKER 1: It's a
sport now, is it?
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: Yeah,
it's kind of like, yeah,
like a video game.
But it's like you can get paid
by the government to do it.
That's how I imagine
it sort of is.
So I think-- so I think I have
just a different mindset about
it all and point of
view about it all,
where I'm actually
emotionally affected by it,
whereas no one else seems
to really be affected by it
on a conscious--
having a conscience about it.
So I don't know if that
answered your question even,
but that's--
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
Yeah, I think so.
No, it was just
interesting to me.
Because I was wondering,
I guess specifically,
that a lot of actors they'll--
especially like for deeper roles
and sort of darker backgrounds,
they'll let it affect them.
And they'll get a little
bit-- in real life,
they'll get a little depressed.
And I mean Heath Ledger is sort
of an extreme of that, right?
But being that
your character does
go to a pretty dark
place near the end,
did you do anything
differently, or you
carry does that carry across
it all in your real life?
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: I don't know.
I mean, probably.
I don't know.
I mean, I definitely like think
about things that really are
happening and that are
perfectly real that affect me
in my real life that I sort of
equate as equivalent to what
this person is
feeling, whether it's
police brutality or
the death penalty
or whatever it might be.
And so I don't know.
I sort of think that
I'm already affected
by it anyways in my
day-to-day life emotionally,
so I just have a different
place to put it, I guess.
SPEAKER 1: You've got
an actual outlet, right?
I want to go back a
second to your saying
that people kind
of skip over you,
thinking that you're just
part of the house staff.
Do they ever go, does
the audience ever
go, Wally, do they go
up to you or Matthew,
do they go up to
you, they're like,
oh, yeah, I loved
you in that movie.
Was it "Lion King II?"
You were the voice of Simba.
Loved you.
That was great, right?
MATTHEW BRODERICK:
"Lion King I" and "II."
[LAUGHTER]
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM:
He was the king.
He played the king.
MATTHEW BRODERICK:
I played the king.
I played adult Simba.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Which is true.
Yeah, do they go up and they
try to-- are you in character
talking to them or
are you just yourself?
MATTHEW BRODERICK: We're--
well, you can't be in character,
really.
People do exactly what
you said all the time.
And so I don't know.
I mean I could say, what
are you talking about?
I've never heard of that movie.
It's an alternate reality.
[LAUGHTER]
I would like to
do that in a way.
Because it might be
good for the show,
but I find it slightly
uncomfortable to talk to--
I mean to talk to strangers is
always a little odd, but fine.
But particularly when
you're in a costume
about to start a show.
You're not quite
sure-- you know,
you're trying to think about
the, in my case, monologue
that I have coming up.
So it's always a little bit--
I don't want to get too involved
in discussing some other job
that I did, and then
pop right into this.
So I sort of try to stay a
little bit removed from it.
But we all do it differently.
You just serve them.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: Well,
yeah, and tell people where
their seats are, probably.
SPEAKER 1: So you know where--
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM:
I've learned it.
At this point, now I know
because so many people
has asked.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SCOTT ELLIOT: But
Wally has a cool thing.
MATTHEW BRODERICK:
He's very good at it.
He talks to people.
SCOTT ELLIOT: He
goes in the audience.
WALLACE SHAWN:
Well, I mean I have
done this for a few decades.
Talking to the audience
before the play is something
I've done at least
since 1990 or so.
So I'm kind of--
well, I've always liked
to talk to strangers.
And I mean, I grew
up in New York
and just to show you how
New York has changed,
my parents were very, very, very
protective of me for that time.
But were not
frightened by the fact
that I would go
into Central Park
and just go up to
strangers and ask them
questions and talk to them.
That was considered
not dangerous.
SPEAKER 1: Back in the day.
WALLACE SHAWN: So yes, I do.
I mean I'm not any better
at it than anybody else.
I mean, I'm quite
awkward and sort of
ask dumb questions
like, I don't know,
uh, uh, where are you from?
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: I think we're all
like that all the time, too.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: Is
that the voice you use?
MATTHEW BRODERICK:
An ogre is coming.
SCOTT ELLIOT: You have
an interesting thing,
because your face
is all bruised,
because he has bruise makeup on.
Because he's beaten up.
He's on his last leg, we'll say.
WALLACE SHAWN: Yeah,
I've been beaten up.
SCOTT ELLIOT: And
so it's interesting,
I've seen you say to some of
the people in the audience
that you might know,
this is makeup.
Some people think it's real.
WALLACE SHAWN: Well, it's--
yeah.
I'm more surprised that more
people aren't alarmed by it.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes, and if the
other person is as
good at having a
conversation, then we
have an interesting
conversation.
And I am quite
fascinated by the fact
that I could write something
and somebody else--
I'm fascinated if they do
understand it or if they don't.
Both are fascinating to me.
And the mystery of being able
to communicate through a play
is fascinating to me.
So I'm very interested
in who these people are.
And also they're
always not remotely
the way you think
they're going to be
when you sort of see
them and you go up
and start talking to them.
It's very interesting.
SPEAKER 1: So I'm going to
pause there for a second.
If any of you in the
audience have questions,
we have two microphones.
So please go and use the mic
so we get it on the recording.
And I want to come back to
what you were saying, though.
Do any of the four of you ever
get feedback after the fact?
Coming up, and either
one or the other of what
you were just saying, of people
saying, that was amazing,
I totally get it, I know
what you're going for.
Or other people just being
like, holy crap, what
did I just watch?
Do you get either
of those at all?
What's your weirdest feedback?
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM:
So I'm younger.
And my friends who are
all in my peer group,
you know, in their
like 20s and 30s
who come and see it, have all
across the board gotten it,
loved it.
And I think when my
grandparents came,
there was a little
bit more confusion.
Even when my parents came,
there were more questions.
But I kind of feel like-- and
I don't mean to be ageist--
but I do think
what I've observed
is that younger
people seem to grasp
the absurdity and the
message and understand it
all really clearly.
And the villain,
I think, which is
this sort of older complacent
person of privilege, which
is a lot of what the audience
is, I think they sometimes
grapple more with what
they just watched,
if that makes any sense.
WALLACE SHAWN: And
certainly the same
play in England,
which had a more--
an older, more
suburban audience,
they don't come up
to me and say things.
But my friends who
are in the audience
have said that there
was a lot of well,
what was the point of that?
Which is what people have
said about my plays--
[LAUGHTER]
--really for my whole life.
It's a very, I mean
that's very natural to me.
But this audience
that's come has been
remarkably responsive to this.
I mean that's
largely because Scott
has built up an audience for his
theater over many, many years.
And they're into it.
Or they're ready to--
SPEAKER 1: Take
whatever you give them?
WALLACE SHAWN: Well,
you can say what's
the point of that about
absolutely anything
if you're not making
the commitment
to try to crawl inside it
and see what might be there.
SPEAKER 1: Scott, he said
you built up the audience.
What he's referring to
is that you're also not
only the director of this
show, but the artistic director
of the whole theater,
The New Group.
What is the difference
between directing
and artistic directing?
SCOTT ELLIOT: Oh, it's fabulous.
Because I don't have
to answer to anybody.
It's my own thing.
I can do whatever I want.
But I think that, well, artistic
directing is essentially
producing.
You figure out what--
and I often think about
what's going on in the world
before I make the choices.
Because The New Group audience,
as Wally said, is, I think,
they're a pretty
with-it audience.
And I would even say that
our older audiences have been
with us for a really long time.
And they're really sort of--
I call them like Peter Pans.
You know, they're not
cranky old people.
They're people who are
actually interested
and engaging in interesting
work and discussing it.
So I think that The New
Group has become sort of-- it
continues to be new.
It's sort of like the young
theater, still, in town.
People often say to me-- we've
been around now 21 years,
but people often say to
me, oh, five years you've
been doing this or whatever.
They think that
because of the work
that we do that we're
very contemporary.
And that's always
sort of been my goal
to never go stale, because
I've watched some of my peers
struggle with that.
And so our audiences
are pretty engaged.
They're not coming
to fall asleep.
They're coming to be engaged.
They're good listeners.
Which I think is so important.
And I think one of the things
that hurts the world in general
is people are not
necessarily good listeners.
There's a lot of--
you know?
SPEAKER 1: There's a lot
of looking down, and being
on your--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPEAKER 1: Device.
SCOTT ELLIOT: Exactly.
Exactly.
But when you come to a New Group
show, even if it's a comedy,
you have to listen and engage.
SPEAKER 1: So now that it's
open, what are you working on?
Now that this is open
and almost closed,
what are you working on.
SCOTT ELLIOT: Oh,
me, oh, goodness.
Well, we have another play
running called "All the Fine
Boys" with Abigail Breslin
which has just opened.
And I'm prepping, I'm going
to direct the show after that,
this play called
"The Whirligig,"
by another actor-playwright,
Hamish Linklater.
But he's not going to be in it.
That's going to be Norbert
Leo Butz and Zosia Mamet,
and a whole other
group of people.
SPEAKER 1: Maura Tierney.
SCOTT ELLIOT: Yeah.
And then I'm planning next year.
That's sort of what
I'm doing right now.
Just sort of figuring
out the shows
that we're going
to do next year,
and we'll be announcing
those in a few weeks.
SPEAKER 1: There've been
a lot of actor-playwright,
like that theme seems to
be recurring among-- it's
a group of friends.
And everybody here
is now friends
and in love with each other.
But do you prefer,
you personally,
do you prefer writing or acting?
Or I mean, how did
your career begin?
Because you've got credits out
the wazoo-- all of you do--
I mean, you've get credits
out the wazoo from both.
WALLACE SHAWN: Well,
I started as a writer.
And really a director,
now deceased,
called Wilfred Leetch
asked me to be in a play,
even though he knew
I was a writer.
And I had had no
plan really for how
I was going to make a living.
I was just writing
avant garde plays
and going into debt
to friends, basically.
And slowly realizing that that
was a poor plan for the future.
And I was sort of saved
by getting that acting job
and finding that it seemed at
first that my acting was less
avant garde than my writing.
I mean that it
was more likeable.
Then in later years, it's turned
out to be basically the same.
I mean that I'm an
amateur actor, apparently.
Or at least, I'm not--
most people don't--
I can't get a job is
the point I'm making.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, a
question over here.
SPEAKER 3: So Wallace, I got
the fortune to see your play.
WALLACE SHAWN: Oh, my gosh.
SPEAKER 3: And it was amazing.
Just I had no idea what
it was going to be like,
and it was just fantastic.
AP, I have a question for you.
And then Matthew, I have
a stupid story for you.
MATTHEW BRODERICK: Yes!
SPEAKER 3: Real quick.
We were in a restaurant, I
don't know, like a year ago.
And you and your lovely
family were there.
And we played it
super cool, acted
like it wasn't a big deal.
But like I was freaking out.
And then when I went
to the bathroom.
It was one of those cool like
stalls and the sink and stuff,
so everybody uses
the same bathroom,
a unisex I think is the term.
[LAUGHTER]
And when I opened the door, you
were standing in front of me.
And I did this.
And I just walked by.
And that's a stupid story
and it doesn't matter.
But then when I
went to the play,
we also got tickets
to the opening show.
We were at the opening.
And my boyfriend made me
promise I wouldn't tell you
that story, because
it's not a story.
And I didn't tell you
that story that night.
And now I have.
And I feel like I've won.
[LAUGHTER] OK.
MATTHEW BRODERICK: Good for you.
AUDIENCE: And also,
you did a great job,
and thank you very much.
I really enjoyed your
monologue and everything.
But AP, you were my
favorite the whole thing.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: Aw.
MATTHEW BRODERICK:
That's not nice.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 3: You know
slightly favorite.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: No,
I can be the favorite.
SPEAKER 3: You just captured
such a complex character
with so many emotions.
And I just want to know how
did you get into the depression
that your character expresses?
And what does that
feel like to switch
like that, because you
seem fine and then you're
like clearly disturbed.
And like what was
that swing like?
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: It's
probably just what I'm like.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
I just equate it to
things that I'm really
disturbed by already.
And I am a pretty sensitive
person in general.
That's something that my
boyfriend tells me a lot.
That I cry about a
lot of things that
like you don't need to, you
know, be that affected by.
I have no idea, though.
Like I don't even
know why Scott,
like I don't even think I
can do the play sometimes.
I'm like I don't know why I'm
doing this, and if I can do it.
SPEAKER 1: It's good
imposter syndrome.
You'd fit in really
well at Google.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: Right, scary.
I don't know.
I feel very
embarrassed right now.
I don't know.
I think it's pretty
important and pretty heavy
if you want to think
of it that way.
And if you do, then
you can like really
let yourself embrace all
the fucked-up shit that
is our society or our world,
and I guess that's it.
I don't know.
SPEAKER 3: Thank you
so much, all of you.
And Wallace, again.
My boyfriend would
be mad to be here.
He's just so excited about you.
Thank you.
WALLACE SHAWN: Thank you.
SPEAKER 4: So hi.
Thanks for coming.
I feel really sad
that it seems like I
won't get to be able
to experience the show
and get to see it.
It sounds like in
this world that this
is a very relevant show for New
Yorkers and Americans, and just
picturing it in the context of
the current political climate.
When you guys did
the show in London,
was there actually a difference
of reaction with the audience
members?
Because you guys get a
chance to talk to people,
it sounds like, during the show.
Was there kind of a difference
in reaction from the London
audience versus the kind
of how like a New York,
American audience
is interpreting it?
WALLACE SHAWN: Well, yes, I
mean the play, the script was--
well, some people have said even
that I have written other plays
that they were annoyed to
see had the same anxieties
expressed in them.
And for some reason,
I mean, I know
among even my own
acquaintances that there
are certain people who have
been pushed over a certain edge
by Trump, to almost
say to me, wow.
The things that you've
been so stupidly,
boringly saying
for decades, and I
thought you were being
overly hysterical.
I can't deny that you
were onto something.
Things were not OK in
the way that I thought.
I mean, people haven't put
it in exactly those words,
but pretty close.
And weirdly, the London audience
was pre-Brexit and pre-Trump.
So there was this ability
to sort of pretend
that it was about nothing,
and why were we watching it?
Whereas nobody, virtually
nobody, in America
is saying that.
Certainly in New York nobody
is saying everything is fine
and it's all going to be
great, and why are you upset?
So that's just chance.
I mean, maybe if we'd done
the play a year earlier,
that would have
been the response.
I don't know.
SPEAKER 4: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Another question?
SPEAKER 5: I have a
question for Wally.
Well, first I want to
say thank you so much
for "My Dinner with Andre."
It's one of the most wonderful
movies that I've ever seen.
Thank you.
But my question was
sort of, I guess,
related to that, in that
you have, with that being
a major exception, you have
these two parallel trajectories
as being like an actor in
films and like a playwright.
[INAUDIBLE] writing for theater.
You haven't done much
writing for film, right?
And I was kind of curious if
that was something you ever
intended to explore,
being involved
in the world of movies,
and whether maybe
the primary reason
you haven't done so
is more related to the
form of the theater
or different expectations
of the audiences?
I just wondered if you could
speak to that a little bit.
WALLACE SHAWN: Well, this play
is does include quite a bit
about show business that is
based on my having hung around
in the movie and TV world.
There's quite a bit in the play
that reflects that, really.
I mean, the theater, and
movies, it is a very different--
well, I'm not in movies anymore,
because nobody would hire me.
But I'm occasionally
in television.
It's a different universe,
because people are
being paid to be on television.
And it's saying, I don't know.
People walk into the room
with a smile on their face
and a certain sense
because of that check
that they've received.
There's a fundamental
seriousness to theater
because people are
not paid, I suppose.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: No, we're not.
SCOTT ELLIOT: But your writing
is like, "My Dinner with Andre"
could be a play.
You know, because it's
so written, you know.
It has like-- the
writing is so gorgeous.
And in movies,
the image drives--
I mean the writing and
the image drive it.
And I think it's so
hard to write a play.
It's the hardest, I
think, to write, I think.
Writing movies is--
there are programs
that can help you through that.
But writing a play,
you have to have
the skill of being able to get
everything across in the words,
and I think it's hard.
I think it's harder
than writing a novel.
Or I mean, I've never
even attempted it,
because I find it
so intimidating.
But I have dashed off a
couple of screen things,
I have to say.
So it's a little bit easier.
And also, movies are very
collaborative in that way.
And plays are very,
very, very much
about what the
playwright is saying
and what the
playwright has written.
In movies, they throw out the
scene if they feel like it.
SPEAKER 1: And if
you do it badly,
you do it again or
change the line.
SCOTT ELLIOT: Exactly.
You can cut around it.
MATTHEW BRODERICK: Have
you ever written things
directly for the screen?
WALLACE SHAWN: No, no.
I've just-- I'm too afraid
it would never be made.
And that would upset me so much.
I've wanted to.
I still would like to.
SPEAKER 1: We should all
produce, in this room.
We will produce.
I'm speaking for all of you.
We will produce this film.
There you go.
You've got budget.
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM:
We could be in it.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNAPURNA SRIRAM: No,
no one will hire me.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: All right, cool.
Everybody, give them
a round of applause.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]